the best way to stay inspired is to help
people the more you help people the more
you're going to love your business and
the more money you're going to make hi
I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today makes me question from a YouTube
viewer Harvey who wrote insane Evan I'm
having a hard time inspiring myself so
whenever I have that feeling i watch
your videos to get hyped again I'm happy
I could help great channel and what can
I do to have more self motivation thanks
Harvey hey welcome to the club it's hard
being an entrepreneur I don't know very
many entrepreneurs who wake up every day
super excited ready to go never get down
you know everybody at some point hates
their business thinks about quitting
things about doing something else it's
hard to keep motivated and you could
have one great day be on top of the
world then you wake up the next morning
and you're starting from scratch again
you got to drag yourself out of bed what
I find really helps me is when I know
and feel like I'm helping people at the
very early stages when I had no customer
feedback what I would do is I used to go
and do training seminar so I trained
entrepreneurs I hold free seminars with
the YMCA and I had feedback forms that
people had to fill out and I would take
those comments and read them every day
when people say hey you changed my life
you open my eyes thank you so much for
everything you've done for me at least
that gets me excited they gets me
wanting to do it again and I try to
think back to those times and how much I
help those people and I wake up wanting
to do it again now honestly it's YouTube
comments I wake ever up every morning I
get my lentils for breakfast and I open
up my email and go to the YouTube
channel section that I created and I
read all the comments and a reply to the
comments and that makes my morning and
it sets me up for the day I see all the
great feedback that you guys are having
saying how you like my channel comments
like yours saying what you don't feel
inspired you wash my channel hey that
makes me feel good that you want to do
more videos so I built that positive
loop in so every morning I start my day
off well when you feel like you're
helping people when you feel like you're
doing the right thing and you're doing
good
people are getting value from what
you're doing it gives you energy so I
don't know what your business is I don't
know what you're trying to do but your
happiness will come from providing that
value try to think about what you've
done already to help people even have a
print out by your bed or you know by
your breakfast table of comments that
people have left of how you've helped
them and change their lives you make
things easier for them thank you so much
you'll read those and get inspired to
want to do more that's the best way at
least that I found for me to help keep
me inspired so thank you for watching
video and please give it a like
underneath thumbs up and the comment
right I just told you that these
comments are so important for me keeps
me motivated here so you want to go so I
want to hear your comments if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up and
again leave a comment about this topic
or again about your business you have a
business question here I want to help I
want to try I read them every morning I
respond every morning so thank you guys
so much and I'll see you soon